as a friend of mine overseas said and i
think andrew this this summarizes it in
just kind of one statement from an
outsider right he said wait a minute
hang on let do i got this correctly do i
have this correctly
you're telling me that in the united
states in order for a candidate or a
party to be on the ballot it has to be
approved to be on the ballot by the
opposition and i said yeah that's right
i mean that's the crux of the system we
have here is is that the political
parties are in control of the process
that puts them in power
[Music]
and look who's back it's zach you
thought that we weren't gonna see him
again zach how's your summer been
probably 50 50 of the audience like oh
great zach's back or others like ah this
guy again but i'm good man it's gonna be
back fam so we're back and we're gonna
talk about a couple of things so later
in the program i'm joined by matthew ho
u.s senate candidate in north carolina
to talk about ways the dems are kind of
playing a little bit dirty
uh and the the two ways that me and zach
are going to talk about number one
is that democrats have now pretty
consistently
been elevating even spending seven
figures on boosting
extreme
election denying january 6 supporting
republican candidates in various
primaries all right i want to say this
i let me ask your opinion this andrew i
don't have a particular problem with
democrats quote playing dirty when i say
dirty is like i don't mean illegal i
just mean like
maybe some below the belt or strategic
decisions because
republicans do it all the time they are
like unashamed in terms of how often
they do that so i think it's nice that
dems punch back but i don't know if you
i think it's tough to win if you're
trying to have this like moral authority
out there and your opponent's just
running ragging working
you know i i'm with you like i actually
appreciate uh anyone who who is
uh
willing to try and win
um but
i will say there's something deeply
hypocritical
about saying look this set of extremists
uh are a threat to democracy
and then saying hey we think we have a
better chance of defeating them in the
general so let's spend a million bucks
on boosting them
um
because you're playing with fire i mean
the fact is there were so many democrats
who were celebrating donald trump's
nomination in 2016 because they're like
oh my gosh like hillary's going to crush
this dude this thing beatable
uh he's the most beatable so my big
reflection is that this is all a
terrible symptom of a perverse two-party
system
that if you have this bipolar
approach then you're like okay let me
nominate the crazy on the other side so
that my sane person can defeat the crazy
but oh look i just increased the chances
of the crazy person getting elected even
though they're out of step with the
mainstream and there are two very
notable races where the democrats have
gone pretty heavily in for the crazy
doug mostriano governor pa and dan cox
governor
maryland both you know like out of step
with what you'd say is the mainstream
but you're playing with fire because you
get you you know you be careful what you
wish for you know and and i'm gonna say
this is a bigger problem
in pennsylvania than maryland i actually
expect in maryland
it's a blue state like very blue
and uh i think it's going to be westmore
uh for the democrats uh who i like and
admire a great deal i think wes moore
crushes dan cox like maryland's a pretty
freaking deep blue state i think joe
might have won by 30 points or something
like that like so whatever they did on
that side it's like i don't like it but
it's not going to bite them in the ass
it is there's a real chance it bites
them in the ass in pa because pa holy
crap i mean that state is like you know
razor thin
so you're going to have uh
doug mastriano uh versus josh shapiro in
pa
and
uh i think pa is gonna be very very red
this cycle so you you might actually be
delivering
uh a crazy person to the
governor's mansion in pa
that one strikes me as irresponsible
it's like look you know you know like
we're really going to take a chance that
we have the crazy i think uh doug
mastriano literally like was at jan6 i
think he like took a bus there or
something he bust people out there yeah
so like that like even if you're a
democratic donor you're like yeah like
give my money to elevate doug mastriano
i mean that that does so again this only
makes sense in the totally messed up
two-party system it's gonna bite them
the ass there are democrats who are
rooting for trump to run because they
they think he's the most beatable uh
republican presidential candidate um
because you know joe's
pretty unpopular and so they're like you
know who can defeat donald trump it's
like like what sane person would be
rooting for
donald trump to run again and then say
oh by the way he's an existential threat
to democracy like so so that stuff
bothers the [ __ ] out of me where it's
like you you're rooting for
perverse things because of this broken
down two-party system and you think you
can eke out a win against a crazy person
and so taking a risk
that the crazy person might win is
acceptable to you what you're talking
about political playbook reported on
this was the dga the democrat
democratic or democrats governors
association the association of governors
that are all on the dem team
they are spending a million dollars
which probably means at least a million
dollars that's a million dollars that we
know of on pumping these people up
they're literally buying ads for them
i think that's ridiculous the fact that
you're gonna donate someone's gonna
donate to the dga
and they're gonna be used to spend money
bumping republican candidates um
fundamentally ridiculous guys especially
in a let's call it pro-republican
environment right like a red wave
midterm environment that's where i am
absolutely ridiculous and this is and
and they're defending it to the press
right they're like
like
boasting
this as like a brilliant strategy it's
not it didn't work 2016. this is stupid
if i'm donating to if i'm going to be a
democrat i should be pumping up
democratic candidates that's the point
and you end up in this situation where
or it might not even be the worst in the
world to even like feel negative ads
about your opponent i think like okay
don't love it but acceptable
um yeah what seemed messed up is like
hey
um boost the crazy
because we think the crazy person who by
the way is an existential threat to
democracy and you know uh on one level
but it's like you think that our chances
of beating them are better according to
our genius projections which you know
we've been known to screw up so like you
know negative ads acceptable not great
but you know it's politics you know it
goes these are literally pro
republican ads right
yeah they're designed to to make the
crazy person seem uh
like the the better choice among the
republican party now here's here's the
other thing this i was gonna say
why do these republic why do these
governor races matter one they matter
very much on a state level depending on
the state they matter very very in terms
of what what gets put into law at a
state level big time but the other thing
that i think the republicans very much
understand is that strong state
leadership a strong governor
can turn that state
harder or or could flip it but turns it
more red or more blue right if you have
a strong republican governor
more people turn out for said republican
governor and you're more likely to get
red senators and red congressmen and
women and red state legislators and red
presidential elections that's what
happens um because they're the leader of
the party in a lot of people's eyes
particularly in that state so
uh that's why they matter and when these
are done poorly and i would argue that
dems haven't been great about this you
don't get the bench of leadership but
you also don't get that turnout bump
from having a strong example of what a
good republican or a good democratic
leader looks like so this is why it
matters in my opinion or even having a
secretary of state from one party or
another in that states act because
they're gonna certify these elections in
various ways well that's a good way too
yeah for this upcoming election or you
know like women's reproductive rights i
mean the governor can uh sign those and
things into law or veto them the other
big thing that uh i was just in nevada
uh this weekend went to nba summer
league was a fun time if anyone's in
town and is a hoops
uh junkie so because you have to be a
bit of a junkie to go to nba summer like
honestly but anyway nevada has this
massive massive ballot initiative
for november
that would
shift them to open primaries and rank
choice voting alaska style
uh and it's a big deal they got
over 200 000 signatures for it uh and
the democrats in their eternal wisdom
have looked at it and said what open
primaries and ranked choice voting don't
like it and they've spent a million
dollars trying to fight it
um i just heard today that the
polling
has it at 60 percent pass because if you
ask nevadans hey do you want to be able
to vote for however you want like do you
want to have one balance at a three
right now they have three ballots like
uh you know
segregated by party even the term
segregated ballot seems kind of dark
doesn't it
uh and so so the majority of nevadans
are like yeah i'd like to be able to
vote for wherever i want in the primary
but the democrats and their consultants
determine that we increase competition
to them and so they're trying to to
kneecap it in any way they can
uh and it's going to probably go down to
the wire
as per usual
so in november nevadans are going to be
able to determine whether they want to
be able to choose whoever the heck they
want from any party
um and i i really really hope it passes
it's a very very big deal it's the only
state where this is on the ballot this
year so uh if you're in nevada
vote yes on this thing tell your friends
that this ballot initiative will give
you more real choice and accountability
in your representatives uh and even if
you're not in nevada uh you know like
check out
forward nevada and let's see if we can
get this thing done but the fact that
the democrats are fighting this uh makes
me sad and mad um though maybe i
shouldn't be surprised you definitely
shouldn't be surprised do you get more
pushback on ranked choice voting and
ballot initiatives and things like that
it's basically open primaries and ranked
choice voting who do you get more
pushback from republicans or democrats
you know i mean that's like the problem
with our current system man it's like
like whichever party thinks it helps
them or hurts them you know what i mean
like if you if you were to say hey open
primaries and rank tours voting to most
people they'd be like sounds good um but
then if you put it in a particular state
they're like does it hurt my team or
help my team
uh and you know it just helps the people
um you're seeing this in alaska and this
is where another crucially important
race so if there are races that i think
are super important
in november one of them is evan mcmullen
in utah two is lisa murkowski in alaska
and the latest projections are this
check it out lisa murkowski voted to
impeach donald trump uh and and so her
approval rating among republicans
crashed down to as low as six percent so
in a normal primary system she's out
she's getting the liz cheney uh by the
way liz cheney is down by 20 and will
almost certainly lose so if you're a
republican who votes against trump you
lose the republican primary that's
the rule more or less
uh but in alaska they got rid of the
republican primary so now uh lisa is
just essentially like in the equivalent
of a general environment and it's open
primaries and ranked choice voting and
the last poll i saw
said that in the final round of ranked
choice voting after all the other
candidates wash out lisa murkowski beats
the trumper
uh 52-48 now she would like that is
tight oh yeah right so she would have
completely lost in a republican primary
because again like you know i mean trump
went and had a rally for his
uh personally endorsed crazy person
yikes yeah so the rules change in alaska
like are genuinely uh the only reason
why lisa murkowski has a chance and also
why she felt the freedom to vote to
impeach trump um and so nevada is the
only state that might turn the dial in
the same way
alaska is a red state nevada is a purple
state so
really this is just a win for the people
and anyone who's genuinely for lowercase
d democracy should be for it but to your
point zack
people get four against it based upon
you know their jersey um one thing that
made me super sad
is that
this was actually our version of it was
on the ballot in massachusetts like the
deepest blue of the states
uh and people who are frankly very very
savvy and forward democracy reform
generally and the rest of it
and then the democrats in massachusetts
came out against it and you're like why
would you do this and it narrowly lost
it lost like three points so this is the
only place that's on the ballot this
november is nevada um so i'm i'm super
engaged with it i'm gonna come back
nevada uh prior to november for sure to
fight for this ballot initiative
democrats please stop spending donor
money on extreme uh candidates on the
other side focus on our own candidates
let's build our own bench up um
you know what i'm saying yeah yeah i
mean you know the next generation for
sure um you know another theme i'm going
to throw in here is try and step aside
for the next generation i know that
there's like a
massive appetite for that and
our guest
uh is going to tell a very very
important and compelling story
about what the heck is happening on the
ballot in north carolina so now
matthew ho u.s senate candidate for the
green party in north carolina joins me
to say what the heck did the dems do
there
and now a word from our sponsor better
help we all get down in the dumps even
in the summer even when the weather is
good you turn on the news and you're
like oh my gosh like which way is the
world heading sometimes these thoughts
are completely normal and you're just
processing but sometimes you could
actually use some honest-to-goodness
help in therapy
and i saw a therapist for the first time
myself when i was in my teens swore by
it ever since i've had family members
who've turned it around thanks to
professional help
you can have a therapist of your own on
call
offering video phone and even live chat
only therapy sessions yes therapy via
chat so you don't have to see anyone on
camera if you don't want to it's more
affordable and you can be matched with a
therapist of your own in under 48 hours
our listeners get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com
yang that's betterhelp.com
[Music]
this week on ford we welcome u.s senate
candidate in the great state of north
carolina for the green party matt ho
matt welcome hey thanks andrew i
appreciate being here so you made
massive headlines recently because well
they're not as massive as i think they
should be but you know we're trying to
help with that
so first what drove you to run for u.s
senate on the green party sure i was
asked to run by the green party but it
was something um that wasn't uh
uh you know abhorrent to me it wasn't
anything i said no absolutely not
you know i took some time to think about
it because i do have some
disability issues pertaining to my time
in the marine corps but uh you know
eventually i decided to go with it uh
and do this because you know in line
with what you all are doing i don't
believe the two-party system uh is
fruitful i believe it's corrupt i
believe it's undemocratic and it's
harmful and then if you believe that you
have to do what you can
to
change it
and so um i've been voting uh third
party for a while now when i feel it's
appropriate or when i when the candidate
matches up with what i believe in um but
for me it was also this this idea beyond
that issue of what our democracy looks
like and how there's a need to to reform
it to rebuild it you know and to
reimagine it basically uh is you know
the lack of accountability um for the
wars whether they be the wars overseas
or say things like the wars on drugs the
economic injustice uh and the the
urgency of the suffering right now the
the the the cost of those wars the cost
of those economic justice the ongoing uh
consequences of the climate crisis uh
all those things that we have had no
organic ability for and we're also not
doing anything to rectify so i think
that puts it into the package of why am
i here talking to you why am i am i a
green party candidate for u.s senate um
you know and uh
and as you kind of uh you know as we're
here to talk about why that's such a
threat to the two-party system well
thank you for your service matt so when
the green party came and talked to you
about this what were your considerations
and then what got you to take the plunge
because as someone who's been a
candidate it's obviously a big
commitment yeah you know again a lot of
it was with health issues and disability
issues for me just whether or not i'd be
able to uh uh be able to to physically
uh do this but uh you know i've got
great doctors and and support the va
with with a base of a traumatic brain
injury so i'm able to uh i'm able to do
this because i have had such great
support and i've got such a great team
around me and everything however uh you
know the considerations were how do i
look at the children in my family
you know how do i look at the kids in my
neighborhood and in 20 or 30 years say
you know at some point somebody asked me
to try and do something about all of
this
and i decided it was too difficult or i
decided it was more lucrative for me to
do something else or i decided that you
know it was going to be um
too uncomfortable you know and i just
mean you mean you don't make tons of
money or get tons of acclaim as an
independent third candidate i'm andrew
i'm like scrooge mcduck man swimming
through all my uh your riches yeah um
yeah you know it is it it's something
that uh is a real concern
and that's something that really limits
our political process as well because
most people know in order to do this you
have to be
particularly if you're running say like
a statewide race but at really any race
the amount of time and effort you need
to put into it
it's very difficult to do it if you are
not in a position where you are
otherwise working for uh full-time uh
just because the the the the the the
amount of of labor time uh you know that
you have to put into this is really
great and that's that's a form of voter
suppression the way that it really we
have a system that really allows for the
wealthy to be in politics and excludes
others yeah and it's true i've been in
races where just about everyone else was
on the government payroll and you know
you're just out there
making it happen so you all did make it
happen uh you all got tens of thousands
of signatures to get on the ballot can
you describe that process and then what
happened next
sure so for an order for the north
carolina green party be recognized as a
political party here in north carolina
we had to collect signatures could do a
petition effort to get onto the ballot
and we we needed 13
865 valid signatures and just to take a
step back for people who are not
familiar with the petitioning process
it's quite normal and in fact when you
look at historically petition efforts
for every four signatures you collect
only three uh usually are verified or
validated or count towards your total
and that's just not here in north
carolina that's across the country
that's because people write the wrong
address down they think they're
registered or not registered you know
nothing insidious or nefarious
just the way it is so we needed 13 865.
uh we collected 20 more than 22 500 and
of that number uh almost sixteen
thousand fifteen thousand nine hundred
fifty three were verified by the county
boards of election which are the
approval authorities uh in north
carolina uh we presented those to the
state on june first we had 2100 more
signatures than were required uh the
state took uh this is where the story
really develops and becomes what we're
talking about here today and why uh this
is such a big deal not just here in
north carolina but across the country
because what basically happens is in a
brazen partisan effort a brazen partisan
manner
the state board of elections which is
composed of three democrats and two
republicans votes along party lines not
to certify us even though we had again
almost 200 more signatures than we
needed and basically on their whim and
basically on this idea that there
potentially could be fraud something
that we've not seen the evidence of we
were afforded no due diligence um the
state board of elections backed up the
process to the last possible day so that
even if they had certified us we would
not have had the time to get all the
other necessary things done to meet that
july 1st deadline so there was bad faith
on the state board of elections part but
also too uh you know the the main aspect
was this decision
again by the democrats on the state
board of election don't get me wrong if
we were a conservative movement the
republicans would have been against us
the democrats for us and what it does is
basically says they basically say
because there could be these issues of
which we're not providing evidence or
telling you what they are but because
there could be these issues there
potentially could be more and because
there could be more we need more time
but because tomorrow is the deadline for
certification we don't have time to
investigate so we're not going to
certify you um you know and again um the
the evidence was never shown to us we
were never given the opportunity to
defend ourselves uh we were never told
whether any of these concerns were about
the signatures that were verified as far
as we know they were strictly you kind
of know what the concerns were true
truly matt so again just to lay out the
math
you guys present 22 500 signatures the
county board says hey sixteen thousand
of these are good to go
the requirement is thirteen thousand
eight hundred fifty so you are well over
that threshold
uh and then they
deny you ballot access because of
quote-unquote concerns uh and
this is one very very clear
manifestation but the democrats did some
other things too like they sent people
door-to-door to have them rescind their
signatures right right so in parallel to
what we're dealing with in the state
board of elections
uh almost as soon as we turned in our
signatures um the democratic senatorial
campaign committee in washington dc got
involved along with elias law group
which is
mark elias's law firm mark elias
argually the most prominent democratic
attorney in the country the elias law
firm bills himself as the biggest and
strongest democratic party law firm in
in the country almost immediately they
get involved they get our petition
records uh from the state
in our lawsuit that we have now uh one
of the one of our
arguments is that the governor's office
colluded with the governor's office was
supposed to be a non-partisan executive
agency colluded with the elias law firm
to get them these records they take
these petition records they match up the
petition records with what we assume are
their donor databases because we're not
sure how they got the phone numbers
otherwise and they start calling people
and they start texting people they start
showing up at their homes and the
arguments they're using are purely
political arguments and at times they're
also saying things like we know that the
green party committed fraud which is you
know saying things that's not true but
they go a step farther because sometimes
they would call and say they're with the
democratic party other times they would
refuse to say who they were working on
behalf of and then what we have we
learned and we got recordings of this
they would call people and say we're
calling from the green party asking you
to take your names off the petitions you
sign for us which makes absolutely no
sense but that's what they did they were
also when they are they are calling
people and saying and when they're
visiting their homes uh saying they're
from the state board of elections office
or from the secretary of state's office
so again deliberately lying to people
you know misleading and manipulating
them in order to try and get their names
to be removed from petitions uh you know
i'll say something that again we
collected more than 22 500 signatures so
we talked to tens and tens of thousands
of people over the period of months not
once was ever was a complaint ever filed
against us by anyone out there saying
hey these guys are doing something shady
it's pretty obvious what you're doing
you're trying to get them to sign to get
the green party on your ballot i mean
like who the heck could be confused by
that
it says it right on the petition sheet
itself and we've got our green party
shirts on we got our literature our
pattern
what that interaction is there's a
person wearing green party paraphernalia
saying will you sign this petition to
get us on the ballot yeah so where this
gets where this of course as people
would expect
we get hit as soon as elias shows up
though complaints start coming in that
passed through the elias law group again
the law firm working on behalf of the
dscc uh and again we never had a
complaint until this law firm shows up
from dc um but then as soon as the law
firm from these
shows up you start having actual fraud
right where they are calling people
lying to them uh trying to mislead them
and manipulate them and harass and bully
them into getting them to remove their
names or petitions or say things such as
we deceived them or what have you and
again all false but this is what is done
and has been done for decades to keep
third parties and independent candidates
off the ballot
so as we say you know this is not
surprising to us maybe the brazenness of
it is but we knew what we were getting
into we were wading into the alligator
pit you know i mean so we knew what to
expect uh and this is a good fight it's
a worthy fight it's a fight that we want
to have because it validates what we're
saying but also too it's a very
important fight because what you're
we're talking about here
on this fight you want the the fight to
be
actual
ballots and voters you don't want to be
embroiled in these ridiculous lawsuits
because they're they're kicking you off
the ballot but you all have made common
cause with the libertarians of north
carolina is that right correct and i i
think across the country third parties
often work together uh because they're
up against the same obstacles right up
against the same institutional hurdles
in terms of getting on the ballot so and
we have with the libertarians here uh
worked before with them uh and certainly
the support we've gotten from them has
been great uh and what they're providing
is context and background to this that
really shows that this was a targeted
partisan effort by the state board of
elections to keep us off the ballot uh
the executive director of the north
carolina libertarian party brian irving
who's been doing this stuff for 30 years
uh said last week look i've been a part
of eight petition drives and never once
has the state board of elections uh
looked at signatures particularly uh
signatures that have been verified by
the account you've been verified by the
county board yeah i think i don't want
to set the stage for people here's what
i think is happening
uh you have a senate race that people
believe will be competitive between the
democrat and the republican
uh and they believe that if you are on
the ballot you will take
energy from the dems uh and and not the
republicans and so they think you know
what if we can manage to kick them off
the ballot it
elevates our chances of winning uh i
think that's what most people imagine is
happening do you think that's a fair
assessment well that that goes along
with the spoiler uh motif or the spoiler
trope
i reject that i'll take on the take on
the title of disrupter though and
certainly what we want to do is disrupt
the political system force the political
system to change right if we run
multiple candidates uh if parties in a
system that is is being kept as a
two-party system it will disrupt the
system and eventually the system will be
forced to change i mean that's that's
one of the strengths you know i'm on
board with this map i mean what i've
been championing is look just adopt rank
choice voting and then anyone can vote
for whomever they want that's that's
exactly right we we um you know one of
the things that will i also say about
all that is that if we're not on the
ballot issues like single-payer health
care uh affordable housing annualized
living wages uh action on the climate uh
ending the war on drugs things like that
are not going to be on the ballot uh
what we represent is a clear alternative
to the other parties and by that
extension what we say is that what the
threat is is that these issues that we
represent issues that
predominantly are
meant for working families so we are
providing a representation for working
families that they don't otherwise have
these are issues that are a danger to
the profits of the donors of both the
democrats and republicans and that's why
they are so eager to keep us off is to
protect their donors profits and they
just simply do not want any discussion
of say health care this is something
that i get so frustrated by matt is they
like they run around yell spoiler
spoiler you're gonna mess it up you're
gonna mess it up and then you turn
around and say well if you really think
that's a problem just adopt ranked
choice voting yeah and then problem
solved and their response is not oh
that's a great idea let me look into
that uh it's instead like it puts paid
to the fact that uh what they don't care
about
uh a real solution or a process
improvement um they just want you to
shut up
that's really you know it's it's such
like a
ridiculous uh uh argument uh because
when you give them the real answer they
they just ignore it completely
you you uh you you say it very well
andrew because because that's been the
experience uh since we started this
campaign back in january but most
especially over the last uh month or so
dealing with this issue
that's exactly right i mean there are
answers there uh you know it's similar
to the whole thing of of both bush and
trump being elected by the electoral
college well let's fix that let's change
that then because that is undemocratic
and it's give it's delivering awful
results for the country i mean but again
the idea that we're going to do
something that fundamentally improves
the circumstances in which we're what
we're we're dealing here and has an
actual positive effect on the outcomes
it always seems to be
missing from the conversation and it's
because both parties the two-party
system as you know wants to maintain the
status quo
and it's a that's a status quo it's
deadly for many many americans but it's
good for the two-party system so the
idea that they're going to talk about
ranked choice voting because rank choice
voting when you explain it to people as
you know andrew is very common sense
it's something that could be readily
adopted and it's something that would
make a difference
you know the
democratic efforts in north carolina
remind me of what's happening in nevada
right now which you might not be
familiar with because your head's down
on your race and you have this lawsuit
against the democrats but there is a
ballot initiative in nevada to shift to
non-partisan open primaries and rank
choice voting and so they can vote on it
in november now the democrats are in
control of government in nevada
so they of course came out against it
because
they they see that it would introduce
genuine competition and then you ask why
the heck could you be against this you
literally use ranked choice voting in
your own internal party processes
already so you understand that it would
help
and the arguments they make are that it
would be confusing it disadvantages
minority voters even though
data shows that that's the opposite like
the whole thing it's like i wish they'd
just come clean and say hey we just
don't like competition right exactly
that that that's the whole thing is that
um they have for decades now uh help
because they're in power and you see
that because again like in our case here
with the county with the state board of
elections it's controlled by the
democratic party as a friend of mine
overseas said and i think andrew this
this summarizes it in just kind of one
statement from an outsider right he said
wait a minute hang on let do i got this
correctly do i have this correctly
you're telling me that in the united
states in order for a candidate or a
party to be
on the ballot it has to be approved to
be on the ballot by the opposition and i
said yeah that's right i mean that's the
crux of the system we have here is is
that the political parties are in
control of the process that puts them in
power yeah it it makes me
aggravated when you hear all of these uh
arguments and claims that democrats are
defending democracy
and then in a case like this
uh they clearly are very happy
to
ignore
the rules or the will of the people if
it suits their political interests
correct i mean because i i think and
i've heard this from many people and
i've heard this from independents
democrats republicans about our our
circumstance because we are getting very
good media on this including national
media and really appreciated be here
able to talk to you about this and tell
tell your folks about what's going on
you know when you look at it objectively
and this idea of of that basically what
the state board of elections has said is
that
we don't like what's happened here we
don't agree with it
and we think there could be something
wrong we have no evidence so we're not
going to approve it and there's not that
big of a distance from what the state
board of elections the democratic party
here in north carolina has said
in their ruling not to certify us and
what giuliani and all those crooks were
saying back in 2020 when they went to
court to try and overturn
the uh 2020 presidential elections that
there could be fraud and so you can't
certify these results and when they were
asked what's the evidence they were of
course unable to provide it because
there was no fraud or or rigging in the
2020 elections and that's what we're
dealing with here too there was no fraud
on our part there was no rigging but
what you have is the political party in
power that it feels threatened by us is
able to say we think there might be and
that's justification enough to keep you
off the ballot and that's why this case
what we're dealing with here i think has
national implications because if they
are allowed to get away with that
you know that has repercussions across
the country in every state in every
municipality et cetera that where a
party in power wants to keep others out
yeah the rules have to apply even when
you don't like the
the impact in a particular case you know
that's like the point of the rules
that's the whole we trump it all the
time about free and fair elections
and that's part of it fair means
oftentimes with fair it means simply
that you don't like the results but you
accept them because again there were
agreed upon rules we have something that
has been set up that tries to be
objective uh and not biased and uh you
know again we just keep coming back to
the same thing right that's not what
we're dealing with here and i think you
know we we had our first day in court
yesterday we're suing the state board of
elections we had our first day in court
yesterday and and we're very
we feel very positive after seeing the
court's initial response to us because
the court is taking this very seriously
and um you know the idea that there was
no due process that this is just the
whim of a political party to keep
another party out is something i think
that the court uh uh takes again very
seriously and so um i think moving
forward
hopefully again this that this
case has an effect across the country in
terms of improving the circumstances of
the situation of ballot access for
independence in in third parties and
grassroots campaigns uh uh you know not
just here in north carolina but you know
wherever elections are being run well
thrilled to hear that they're taking it
as seriously as they should you have a
lot of people in your corner who want to
make sure that the will of the people is
actually represented
that if you do all this work and i know
it's hard to get 22 500 signatures like
if you do all this work that they don't
arbitrarily kick you off the ballot if
people want to help you
this lawsuit
your campaign how can they do so
right so please go to
matthewhofersenate.org
uh last name spelled hoh some
matthewhofercent.org and please donate
encourage others to donate we are up
against uh we're in a two-fight front
here we are against both the north
both the state of north carolina and the
democratic party not the north carolina
democratic party but the democratic
party chuck schumer's operation in
washington d.c and their biggest law
firm so it's a real david and goliath
fight we are up against the leviathan if
you will and we need people's support
because this will be a very expensive
ballot access in general is uh something
i don't think people really have a great
familiarity with because it doesn't get
discussed as much but it really is uh uh
onerous on both the front end and the
back end so you spend
all months and months of your campaign
just trying to get on the ballot because
as you were saying andrew it takes a
long time to collect signatures it's a
lot of effort ends up costing you money
which third-party independent and
grassroots campaigns don't have and then
on the back end after you turn them in
you get hit
with these legal and bureaucratic
attacks
that you then have to fend off and
that's where we are now in court uh so
it will be very costly for us but if you
agree with us and you want to see us win
please support please donate and please
encourage others to donate at
matthewhofersenate.org that's hoh
matthewhoh for senate.org
wish you the best of luck making this
case for the people of north carolina to
have a genuine say and who represents
them thank you so much again for your
service for running and waging this
campaign man and now becoming in many
ways
uh one of the symbols for third party
and independent politics in the entire
country well thank you for saying that
andrew and thank you for the work you're
doing um i really appreciate the
leadership you've been showing on these
issues i mean the fact that you went
into it you saw what was happening and
you said this isn't right
and i'm gonna do something about it
that's really inspiring so thank you for
what you're doing as well
oh matt i i love the people who are in
third party in independent politics
because
you're generally genuinely driven by
service patriotism principle like i joke
like no one goes into this area before
like the riches in glory
because you know the system is broken
and the people deserve better well and
people are hurting and it's people we
love and there's no one who's a part of
this campaign who's not doing this
because they've had some personal
experience or they have people in their
lives who they love who are suffering
people i have people in my life who
in it who have to check their banking
accounts before they go to the doctor
and then they make dangerous decisions
based upon how much money they have and
i could talk about my neighbors who've
lost homes to corporations and the
number of people i know who've died from
opioid overdose i mean like this is a re
you know when i say this this is real
for me this is real for me people i love
are suffering and it's because of the
deliberate
government policies uh that come keep
coming back to me to the two-party
system and it's captured by money that
creates the circumstances that the
people i love suffer under yes well
people wonder what the democratic party
is doing in a lot of the country and one
thing that they seem very adept at is
kicking people off the ballot uh
hopefully this is something that the
that can get reversed in the days to
come to make sure that the people of
north carolina have you on the ballot
matt appreciate the heck out of you and
hopefully we'll have a chance to to meet
in person but support everything you're
working on right now yeah i appreciate
andrew and again thank you for
everything you're doing thanks matt
thank you so much for listening next
week on forward an exciting announcement
i have been working on for months about
the forward party you do not want to
miss it check it out it's going to come
out probably even before next week but
next week tune in for huge news about
the forward party